foreign
we're back let's go out to Phoenix
Arizona where it's 1 billion degrees and
talk to Rebecca what's up Rebecca
hi it is not quite a billion degrees but
it definitely feels hot it feels hot
because it's a billion degrees I heard
the other day there was 25 straight days
of over 110
uh yeah it was horrible especially we
just moved here from Montana oh so I am
not used to this heat why did you
everyone in the planet is like
eyeball in Montana as the sacred holy
place to escape to and you guys are like
nah we'll move to hell that sounds fun I
know yep that's my husband's doing
I mean you got to reevaluate this
relation I'm just playing I'm playing
um golly I'm and again I'm from Texas
I'm a lifelong Texan and even Texans are
like it's real hot but then looking over
to their left and they're like but it
ain't Phoenix man
our cactuses are falling over
yes heads are falling off all right all
right all right so I'll quit talking
about the the weather what's up
yeah so um I guess I'm just gonna kind
of jump I wrote out my question
okay yeah it's great because I talk too
much that's perfect yeah all right
so I'm a mother of four young kids five
and under and I feel like my patience is
spread just too thin to cover my whole
family hold on let's just stop right
there way to try and be a patient and as
patient and kind with my kids as
possible because I know at the end of
the day they don't mean to frustrate me
as much as they do come on hold on hold
on Rebecca Rebecca Rebecca Rebecca oh
yes sorry you have four kids under five
yes
you are entitled to all the feelings you
would like to have
all of them
there is there is no feeling you are
experiencing right now that makes you
crazy
Rebecca if you said I think about
murdering three out of the four I would
be like yeah that's fair like they're
like you have four kids under five that
makes your house like a bomb went off
inside of it
yeah most days yes and you're left
changing the diapers of all the
survivors that's chaos okay so you are
frustrated and you feel like you're
snapping at people
basically it's just my husband at the
end of the day I I know it's so bad I
like I I've never had problems with
other people too I I'm kind of a control
freak I've been that way for I think all
of my life I'm sure my mom would attest
to that as I'm dressing up my younger
brother in dresses and carting him
around the house telling him what to do
yes you should
um yeah but but I've never had issues
you know it's not a problem when I was
in school it's never been a problem at
jobs
um and even with my kids you know I I
really do I try my best I understand at
the end of the day that teaching them
how I want them to behave is going to be
a process that takes years
um but my husband it's just I I have no
patience no Grace for him it is zero to
a hundred even if it's just the most
minor thing
I just I snap
because you have four kids under five
is he helping at all
yes oh yeah he's amazing he's a he's a
teacher so he's gone for most of the day
but when he gets back and and I mean he
does everything that I ask him to do
but it's it's got to be specific it's
got to be you know it cannot be hey will
you make up some baby food I have to
tell him exactly what needs to be made
how it needs to be made all that kind of
stuff and even sometimes when I do that
he still will do it different ways and
that's almost where I really lose it is
just that it's not done the way I want
it to be done yeah yeah so what happened
when you were a kid and this can happen
you can have great parents this still
happens but somewhere along the way you
learned that you had to be in control of
every variable what does that stem from
um probably I'm The more I've talked to
my mom the more I think that it comes
from the fact that um I'm the oldest of
three and my sister is born with one of
the rarest conditions of arthritis um
she would know everything about it I
just basically know that basically from
the time she was an infant she suffered
um a lot of pain in her joints and
um and and of course you know as an
infant they didn't know what the problem
was and so my mom just did not have time
for me and my brother and she tells me
now that without me there she doesn't
think she would have been able to do it
because I'm the one who got us up and
ready for school I'm the one who made
breakfast I'm the one who when we when
we got home from school was entertaining
my brother where was that letting my mom
sleep and um my dad's a graveyard
um worker he's a sheriff so you know
he's sleeping during the day and then at
work for 12 hours a night you say he's a
sheriff
yes oh fantastic all right so here's
what you have like and and I want to
give you some peace on this okay
um there are some pretty compelling
anecdotal uh huberman calls it anecdata
um
with cops kids of which I am one
oh I didn't know that
know that well yes it is cool but also
comes with a lot of drama because cops
kids
have dads that their entire lives are
lived outside the bell curve meaning
nobody gets murdered in the park
except a hundred percent of your dad's
day is dealing with that one time
someone did and over time it becomes
you know this could happen Rebecca you
know Rebecca hey Rebecca and you put on
top of being a cops kid who's working
the graveyard shift you've been a mother
since you were four
and if you didn't do everything like
your mom said the house shut down
so the stakes have been so high for so
long that if you get one thing wrong
you're out
right your sister goes on whatever your
brother doesn't have food he doesn't go
to school you've been a parent since you
could you should not have been a parent
when you were a kid you should have been
sitting in a mud puddle playing with
sticks
and then you fast forward in that same
skill set kicks in when you have a
chaotic house and I'm making a joke but
I'm being super serious four kids under
five is a lot for a human nervous system
to handle it's a lot
and so your body has one switch it's got
those neural Maps already mapped out
here's how we handle this and then you
have an amazing loving husband who's
like or I could just put raisins in it
and your brain goes and it's and it it
lights him on fire right
yeah
and so your brain is doing exactly what
it's been trained to do
so I want you a to give yourself some
Grace stop going to war with Rebecca
because that's not going to solve this
okay
okay also you're gonna have to keep on a
loop in your mind my husband is not my
dad my husband is not my mom over and
over and over and over again
okay
you had no business running your
household as a little girl and yet you
did
okay and so now what you're gonna have
to practice is
um a couple of things number one you are
gonna have to just flat get over sister
the I don't like telling him all the
details
you're gonna just have to help tell him
all the details what I would tell you is
these conversations are way better had
not in the heat of battle
this is like hey we've got four kids
under five our whole life is different
let's go out and you hear me say this
like I just beat this drum over and over
let's go out and talk about
making breakfast let's go out and talk
about how we do laundry let's go and
talk about some of these things give him
a list of three or four things of the
way you like it done
and um so it'd be super super clean
because here's what happens you you you
are not looking for the results which
are clean clothes or mixed baby food
your body is searching for the action am
I in control of everything
see what I'm saying and here's the thing
you are not and your your body knows
that but your brain's like I want to be
in control
and then I'll then it creates a
self-fulfilling prophecy where he didn't
want to touch nothing because he always
does it wrong and he's just gonna work a
little bit more and maybe he's gonna
stay a little bit later in grade papers
which leaves you on your own more see
how this thing just gets sideways real
fast right yeah
and so and then you get more control Lee
because you your husband's going away
your kids are a little bit crazier
because they miss their dad and you you
grab control a little bit tighter and
then the whole thing just right like one
of those cactus in the Arizona desert
just falling over right yeah so here's
how I want you to practice this number
one I want you to take them out and
distill it down to a few things you
can't live with here's what I mean by
that
my daughter has a peanut allergy I
didn't believe those things were real
and because I was a loudmouth 18 to 25
year old ah the cosmos gave me a kid
with a peanut allergy
when she was born I would take her
places I would go have fun I was trying
to get out of the house and I love doing
things with my one-year-old two-year-old
daughter I would always forget the
little bag with the EpiPen in it and all
that
and one day my wife said hey
if unsuspectingly the wrong thing ends
up in a cookie and you forget and hand
it to her she will die
you cannot forget this bag
and I'll tell you I don't forget that
back
there were some things when it came to
how laundry gets done
that my wife's like hey this is how I
like it done and I would say after being
on the road and working you know 100
hours a week at the University
this is how I can get it done and my
wife said okay that's cool
and so it became I don't want to be in
control I just want clean clothes I'm
going to let these things get done in
this way and then there's a couple of
clothes like hey please don't throw my
nice whatever into the underwear and put
it on hot like because it doesn't work
that you know I mean so there's some
basic things like that so I want you to
be very clear about the few things you
can't live with and without
and then here's number two you have to
practice letting the rest go and here's
how you do that I want you to ask
yourself when you start to feel yourself
snapping
ask yourself
what's the worst that can happen here
and if the worst that can happen is not
death or somebody getting hurt you've
got to practice letting it go because
you got a husband that's shown up that
loves you guys and is trying his best
is that fair
yeah that's going to be the hard part
though that is such a hard time with
that it is but I mean just think about
this think about every time when you
were a little girl with a front door
open someone just hit you in the face
with a cream pie just Splat right as an
adult you would make sure you would
deadbolt that front door because it's
your house now and anytime somebody
started opening it you would just duck
it because you've been in the face with
a pie A Thousand Times Ten Thousand
Times this is the same exact thing
you have to remember what didn't what
what kept me alive then isn't is going
to destroy my marriage now
it's not worth it
and it's not real either by the way and
you know that yeah is that fair so like
go to the other side of this do this
thought experiment with me
just imagine how cool it would feel
to not be angry with your husband
a lot less stressful
so can I say something crazy for some
reason you're choosing stress
if you think about it why why would I do
that I don't know I'm asking you
because that's what that's what your
body knows
your body knows and there's a bunch of
kids we're supposed to feel this way and
what you have to teach your body is no
no no that's how it was one time it's
not going to be that way in my house
because I get to decide what my house is
going to feel like and I'm going for
warmth and I'm gonna go for Joy I'm
gonna go for more laughter than chaos
there's always gonna be chaos especially
with the way you guys did it which is
like hey let's just throw all the
ingredients in the blender at the same
time that's gonna be fine but the
blender is going to get really messy
that's cool but you get to decide and so
that means
that when your husband's taking the
laundry down and you see him put the
t-shirts in with the with the underwear
you ask yourself real quick what's the
worst that can happen nothing
there is no worst here the clothes are
gonna clean
okay cool yeah
can I ask a question that kind of goes
along with that skinny thing yeah
so because I I think I I'm I've been
kind of trying to do something like that
where I tell him more specifically
but
I guess if I ask him to do something
specifically and then I still see later
on that he's not doing it that specific
way do you think it would be better to
still just practice that like okay he
didn't listen this time but nothing bad
is going to happen or yes okay and still
do that but two things one you can't
if you've got a baby on in one arm and a
baby on the other and one Raptor on your
leg and he's holding the fourth
and you're saying you gotta do it like
this and if you do you got to make sure
this and that he is in survival mode he
is not in learning and listening mode
yeah okay and you are not in teaching
mode you are in control mode I am
barking orders because this is what my
body knows
oh I like that a lot teaching compared
to control mode so if you want to teach
somebody
you get down like when I'm going to
teach my daughter something I get down
on eye level with her
because I am humongous compared to her
little body and when I hover over and
say hey her body instantly goes to fight
or flight there is no more learning
happening there
she'll do what I say because I'm
humongous she will not learn why we're
doing what we're doing
so I'll get down and I'll look her in
the eye and say hey
and I'll hold both of her hands if
she'll do that sometimes she will
sometimes she won't and I will say
listen if you put this in that light
socket you will die
don't do that and she'll get real
wide-eyed and I'll say I love you and my
job is to keep you safe right see I'm
teaching her in that moment
okay
so teaching has to be done offline it
cannot be done with kids screaming and
blah blah blah that's why I love like a
weekly check-in husbands and wives and
by the way it's real real important at
your kids age
my wife and I would I would walk in the
door and this sounds cruel and I'm gonna
get a bunch of mean emails I don't care
I'd walk past my kids
I'd say hi guys hi guys and I'd go
straight to Mom and Mom got my first hug
mom got my first attention
and then we would always say I would say
hi to the kids and then I would say
we have to have we're having adult time
y'all gotta go
and they had to leave the room
and they have learned that even we say
we're having adult talk they walk
they'll just get up and leave because
it's just so wired into them that they
just know that's a part of our home
that they come second to my marriage
the kids have to come second to your
marriage
in a strange way they they will go in
their rooms and they'll play and they'll
do silly things and yes they'll whine
and complain and he hit me
cool as soon as we're done with with uh
mom with adult time then we'll we'll
come back but that's the only way you
can hang in there in the chaos you guys
have
okay
tell me what you don't like about that
um I mean just the days are hard
obviously sometimes but
um no I I think I like it overall I
think as you're saying it I recognize
that we don't really spend a lot of time
just talking one-on-one and we have
twins that are eight months old so those
those are the ones that really take up
the most time right um but I'm thinking
like even our quality time that we spent
together is at the end of the day we
both feed a baby together and then once
the babies get in bed he's got to go to
bed because he wakes up early in the
mornings to get ready and he he's such a
nice guy he lets me sleep in a little
bit in the mornings too so he wakes up
early with the babies
um but I mean that's our quality time
and it's not even truly alone we're
feeding babies together and but also can
I say this
you've been pregnant
for six years
and a baby an eight-month-old baby is I
I love this it doesn't make mathematical
sense but it's the fourth trimester
right if you look at evolutionary
psychology we traded humongous brains
for
9 to 12 more months of gestation like of
a baby having to
be attached to his mom so I want to hear
I want you to hear me say this this does
get better
there is a season and you're in it where
you all ride this one out okay
but when you're feeding a baby sometimes
just watching a show my wife and I
watched bones with that show with uh I
forget
I don't know
we still laugh about it like man what my
poor son what he just in what he learned
by osmosis because we watched that show
but there was something that was
important but then there was also
Seasons when my wife was feeding my son
and the TV was just off and we just
talked to each other that was and that
was all we could do that was it that's
all we could have in that season
um otherwise it was gonna get chaotic
and so
eight months will snap your fingers turn
into 12 months
and then when you're 12 months you're
gonna have a five-year-old and a
five-year-old can be in the shower by
themselves a four-year-old can't too or
in the bathtub
and a five-year-old they're not gonna
wipe properly but they can go to the
bathroom on their own and it's gonna
it's gonna slowly be a tiny little
pinhole light at the end of this tunnel
and
the one-year-olds will turn into 18
months old
and then you'll get a little bit of a
gap and the Gap will get a little bit
bigger a little bit bigger so right now
I don't want you to do anything drastic
I want you all to hold on and I want you
all to come up with all right what do we
need to hold on in this season
what do we need to hold on right now we
got twins that are eight months old and
we have a three-year-old and a
four-year-old God help you all that's a
lot of humans
a little dependent humans it may be we
need to get some help and I know he's a
teacher and y'all got a family of six
and so
um there's not a lot of extra income
maybe a friend comes over in the
afternoon my my son did some things when
he was younger when he was about 12 or
11 he would go over and play with little
kids one mom but like a neighbor's mom
did some stuff and it was kind of like a
stay-at-home babysitter-ish kind of
thing my son loved it the kids loved it
and the mom loved loved it and because
he was young she got to pay him a lot
less just a couple of bucks but figure
out ways what do we need here
what do we need what do we need and it's
really hard to do that when you have
babies all attached to you so I would
recommend you guys get away for a half
day if possible that may sound insane
and have somebody come over or two
people come over but y'all plan okay
everything in our life is different we
have to prioritize us first
and we have to get these babies fed
what's that look like for us
what's that look like and you my friend
have to understand there's a light into
this tunnel
and how are we going to continue to
prioritize or prioritize what are the
three or four things I got to be clear
on I'm going to die on this hill and
then yes if you say I need the
laundry done the bed made like this and
your husband does it 85 right let it
ride let it ride ask yourself
what's the worst that could happen here
you guys have got this hang on the line
I'm gonna send you a copy of building a
non-anxious life my new book I want you
guys to use this as a road map for your
family and y'all can create a world
inside of this chaotic ecosystem you'll
have how do we create a non-anxious
world how do we create this